yeah low end welcome to a new video on
this bill also be a premiere for this
channel because um this time I'll show
and do some comentary honor on a classic
game um it's not a well-known game um I
actually I'm only side and I don't know
one or two years ago on because it was
picked by him Grand Master Larry
Christensen for his weekly show on the
ICC way show some nice attacking games
and so maybe those of you also a member
of ICC might know the game but so still
pretty unknown um generally speaking um
yeah I was some this this game came to
my mind because um I played a nice song
nice blitz game recently them on the
game with the number 66 in my list of
blitz games I can also put the link in
the description um because I'm it
featured a line in the Sicilian on that
was also used in this game and yeah
somehow this game was some sort of yeah
inspiration for me to play this line so
it's um it's from 1979 so already more
than 30 years old but it still features
to set up the room that is very much
playable today and this is also um yeah
one positive feature after this line
because it's not so dependent unknown
yeah current opening fashion or
something it so it's more like a general
concept or setup then a specific forcing
line on compared to two other ways to to
combat Sicilian
this game has also meant to introduce a
very interesting player from the past um
I revelry recommend to study his games
and this is FM gala I'm Russian or back
then Soviet Grandmaster he was 119 925
and died 1998 so I'm 73 years old and he
was some very strong player even on
contender for the World Championship
title at some point mainly in the 60s
the only had term the bad luck that at
exactly the same time Boris Spassky came
to came to fame and he simply always got
Spassky as an opponent in the candidate
matches and lost besides these results
he had a tremendous record um was world
champions it's very remarkable he had a
positive score and a clearly positive
score not just one point or something um
against Botvinnik against Pedro sound
smooth Slav and even Fischer he beat all
those people um yeah far more often then
then why's versa so very remarkable in
fact i'm not sure but i think maybe gala
is the only player who who even has a
positive record against Fischer would
need to look it up but if you look at
people who played more than let's say
five six seven games well the sim I
don't think anyone else' was such a
difficult opponent and gala is a very
interesting player to study on if you're
interested in various openings because
and throughout history was very
consistent with the setups and he always
try to refine them so on if you look for
interesting but solid ways to for
instance play the sicilian as white
on my combat is Serena thoai door if you
intend to play the ruler peso Spanish
opening gala is also heavily recommended
he also was very influential on on the
black side for instance of the Kings
Indian on the Sicilian as well from the
black side and also the Queens gambit
declined evening you switched later from
the Kings Indian to the Queens gambit
declined and yes who had a very very
interesting way sometimes too to play
this Sally solid opening to obtain
dynamic positions gala also played a
crucial role in Nam and some World
Championship matches as a second to cap
off I think he also was Spassky second
in the nineteen seventy-two m match of
the century versus Fisher because I
guess they thought maybe Galahad some
sort of secret how to beat for sure but
at the end it wasn't meant to be on gala
then became Karpov so second in the in
the matches against Korchnoi and he's
also yeah somehow responsible for some
lines on that car both played for
instance in the Queens gambit is black
and I'm Sicilian with white all the
stuff that cap of played against
Kasparov and Akash know at some point
was also worked out by gala so ok let's
get to this game um as I said it's from
1979 and this one was one of yeah maybe
galas the finest hour he was already
past his prime actually he was best in
the 60s so 1979 he already was 50 years
old 54 years old and he did win the
Soviet championship back then which was
remarkable achievement because those
tournaments were simply the strongest in
the world um so it's quite funny if you
look at if you look this tournament up
in 1979 so
a championship you even find garry
kasparov and the in the tournament shot
who was 16 years old big vanity finished
third but Geller won this tournament
very nicely okay the game i'm about to
show as opponent is a pretty much
unknown player no international master
at the time um you Rihanna Kai if I'm I
don't know him um the only thing you
always need to know if you look at those
games um black player was rated to 455
and back then this was much much
stronger in comparison to today to
today's rating so you might as well
easily add 100 to 150 points so it would
be grand master easily today so okay um
gala opens with e4 and this was his main
move throughout his career so if you
need for player it's very interesting
even today 30 40 years old games from
gala are very interesting because he was
very yeah he did research on his
openings and it's still interesting to
pick up ideas okay um as I mentioned it
is Sicilian and ask even England
variation here with the classical move
or a v6 d6 not um not a scaling unless
is reached by the night of move water
was d 6 & a 6 i'm here on white actually
would have fun the opportunity to play a
g4 the keris attack which is yeah
oftentimes seen as the main argument
where does this move autumn but the gala
played just wish would be to and this
was his favorite set up was this all
kind of Sicilians um especially against
night off he always played Bishop e2
almost always and also this given in but
the the nice point about the setup I'll
play a couple of moose because they're
very yeah very well known and don't need
to be much commented upon if you look at
this kind of setup from the white side
um this is a setup that can also be
applied for instance where the some the
terminal variation or sometimes you can
get this kind of position from can move
order yeah there are various ways for
black to to build up a position with e
66 and white almost always can go for a
setup which is exactly like this are
very similar maybe with slide
transposition of moves um so it makes
some sense to to pick up to pick some
setup which is which is some similar
were the some various lines to to hear
from ya ideas to to use against more
than one line it's very very large body
of work if you study on different setups
where there's all kinds of Sicilian on
sub variations so it's it's a nice idea
to to go for something like this now
wide in place a form of standard move to
prevent leg from be playing b5 just just
for instance on let's say white wouldn't
play a form would play on some other
move let's say Queenie to for instance
like might might take on deform and go
for for b5 so on white wants to restrict
this and he also they could have done
this also in the the earlier moves these
move orders are very flexible um black
now played Bishop d7 which is
perfectly playable but a bit out of
fashion on nowadays nowadays they mostly
play a Quincy seven here too yeah not to
choose them on square only for the
bishop this was also kasparov's choice
in all those Mitch games with a scar
both in the ages um but ok Bishop d7 s
its okay its playable um no gallop late
Bishop f3 which is part of his setup
here um White's main idea is to
strengthen the center with pieces so
Bishop e3 over protects you for porn and
makes the center more secure and after
whiter security center is we will choose
how to proceed further them um now black
on play down on very rare move I think I
was the only gamer I found with this
move is exactly the game I'm i'm showing
so like never dare to repeat this but
done this is understandable if you watch
the game you played a Knight a5 now um
the main move here and this line also is
Queen c7 um yeah and then then white
continues not be three he likes to
preserve the night and also avoids on
things like let's say King edge one
takes on d4 nanny five which also could
help like freeing us games so white
drops back the night and then it usually
continues along lines of b6 it's also an
essential move here on a black sometimes
try smooth like down our roof see a
drogue fcn or something and he always
needs to be aware that white might play
a five and stops any counter play on the
queenside s the porn and the bishop
prevent a bleep on from moving on this
kind of septa sometimes is playable for
black but and
this position it doesn't look very nice
what just seems to enjoy some advantage
um so b6 is usually played and then
white goes for G form with the idea of
g5 and bishop CA it back to get the
bishop to be 7g 597 this was also a main
point of putting the bishop back to get
the square for the night and then white
continues Bishop g2 if you look at my
blitz game we watched it already this
mentioned one a couple of days ago um
the white position is exactly identical
to the on to this blitz game so um I
just set up this kind of information and
only blacks pieces are was somewhat of
it but only slightly I'm not not
completely sure how it was but just one
or two some slight differences and white
some further attacking plan usually um
consists of switching the root 2 h 3 and
then queen h5 attacking on the King side
so this rather slow buildup often leads
to um yeah to real attacking game so
it's just um yeah let's say a delay in
the in the attacking process it's not as
direct as some other lines where why it
just tries to to hack through to the
King immediately he just don't first
secures his position a bit and then
tries to get active play against the
king um so let's get back to the game he
played Knight a5 it's not an uncommon
idea to try to get to the night to see
form but here it is so not really
justified and we'll see I'm why that is
the case on white now played our Queenie
to a good move to protect was not c4 for
the moment Queen just controls the
square and black plays Queen c7 which
makes sense of course to
have the move Knight c4 again and now on
we see after gallows next move on why
this whole setup is really problematic
he now played G form which we already
saw in now in another line I showed him
a couple moments ago but here black has
a problem that his setup is somewhat
yeah concession congested so to say this
knight on f6 doesn't have an a good
retreating square and he also didn't
want to play a bishop c8 now everything
back so to say because the regrouping
and 95 doesn't really doesn't really fit
together he now played rook c8 in order
to avoid after g5 that G 598 that the
rook is yeah bad on a fate so he moved
the rook to c8 also i think he was still
hoping to get some play along the the C
file um but now it's it's going very
quickly and this was one thing on which
really impressed me about this game how
quickly black really got into huge
trouble here why played g5 now night
back didn't have another square and now
f5 so just in three moves we see g4g 5
f-5 those very quickly and like now
already has got really very concrete and
difficult problems to solve he played
now on night c4k didn't um yeah you
can't play all this moves and then never
go to see for so it makes sense somehow
but if you look at passive moves or
defensive moves for instance let's say
queen d8 with the idea of also taking g5
then why'd woods just simply take on e6
when Bishop g4 the e6 porn is very
vulnerable night c7 to protect this pawn
and then just h4 and we see that white
has just a very strong position like
still is not able to play night see for
this night is offside on a five and
white can just strengthen this position
on the knight on d4 for instance it's
very annoying always press rising e6 and
black cannot play a 65 because it would
just open up the position even more for
peace to come to f5 especially the night
right now is a free hand to to just
build up further let's say can can
double rooks it could switch the Queen
over to get more pressure on on e6 and
this is just terrible to defend so not
c4 i think is this the right move to to
at least get some kind of activity and
now i see also strong move Bishop to h5
this Bishop on f3 which yeah mate is
somewhat passive maybe impression it
just hit the road to protective form now
enters the attack and there's a very
concrete threat now Bishop takes f7 this
is very strong so if black now place um
night x each III and then white would
smash through here with the bishop takes
f7 King needs to take and then F takes
c6 double check the rook on f1 and the
pawn so needs to retreat and now is a
very strong move again nom three techs
III you could also take on these d7
swords of some advantage but Queen takes
III is just completely crushing if black
now tries to save his is bishop on
dissembler tus attacked then why'd
enters on the 7th rank with Regev
and he was just able to get all pieces
towards the king and go from mate this
is just just a lost position let's
continue just a few muse let's say g6
hmm in order to maybe play at least the
night to g7 then Queen h3 if he is
playing lagi 7 now then Queen h6 just
wins so h5 takes and it's just just
horrible black gets completely blown
away it's quite interesting if you've
got some time maybe go through these
lines it's very nice to see that black
gets completely crushed here the rukon
the seventh and the pawn on d6 adjust
adjust deadly ok on so black played g6
their best move from the position to at
least put up some resistance and of
course now it's very logical white opens
up the F fire leg needs to take if he
would take with the H porn it's it's
actually worse in comparison because
what immediately goes on to f7 and
things would run similar as in the game
but that's just a born and have seven
that faults look at the game and then um
compare this you will see that this is
much worse so it took with the f porn
and now the nice intermediate move from
Queen f2 directly going to f7 and this
squares not at all easy to protect it
from absolute 95 was played on black
would take now then what could for
starters play this threatening ruegg f8
mate and I don't see a move actually
it's just lost thing so 95 so very
sensible to cover f7
and now I'm a strong move again so not
not difficult to find but still strong
and very thematic because blacks best
defensive piece is clearly the night so
why plays Knight f3 to remove this and
finally enter on f7 so if he takes the
bishop now on h5 you just take a five
and add to f7 some black plate neither
g7 is the best defense and a white white
could take him and rook f8 this was
blacks idea but White has some strong
continuation it would be much worse now
on to move the queen or retreat a piece
it's just the best move on to play night
to f7 and here you see that the night
will take up a very strong post on h 6
h-6 is or h3 if you see it with Carlos
reverse is often a very strong attacking
square as it controlled squares very
near the King g8 f7 and often assists in
different mating motifs we'll see some
some in the game I'd like now made the
decisive mistake and his position is
very difficult anyway what he should
play now as G takes h5 which looks
really ugly of course but this would
still put up on quite some resistance
for instance some white would play
Knight h6 mm-hmm check king and the
corner Queen g3 with the idea of playing
g6 open up the position even more so let
goes for on Bishop 28 to cover this and
then for instance taking group 2 f1 with
tempo FA de sang with a maid threat so
needs to cover this and then for
instance between f3 threatening Queen
tags ff8 mate you see the night
assisting
um Bishop e7 and then for instance
Bishop to deform whites that has a very
strong attacking position but if you
check this with the computer for
instance it doesn't find forced really
first win it is so dreadful to play but
it's not not a maid in an X moves on wyd
winning a piece or something um so this
would would be the way to put up some
some resistance but in this position
black now took with the night this is a
natural move course and now White has a
very very nice finish and also on a nice
yeah nice mating pageant so to say it's
it's now really what is winning almost
the whole set of pieces on or delivering
mate and the key mudras 95 very often
enough the night sacrifice on d5 is
strong in the Sicilian and this is yeah
really no exception um yeah black needs
to take and snow nothing else as he
seven is also hanging was checked so he
needs to take this and now it's very
nice nine to h6 check King g7 and now we
see one of the the mating patterson
patterns i have promised queen to f7
check rook takes he doesn't have
anything else rook takes King 2 h8
Bishop d4 and now we see the point of 95
95 was just played to have this check
here and to prevent e65 so if you
imagine the same position with the rook
with the porn still only 60 and the
knight on c3 black would play e5 and
would secure his position and now this
check comes with all its force black
needs to of course put a piece on f6 it
doesn't have anything else and now the
finishing touch rook takes f7 it's very
just very nice if if the night takes now
of course it's bishop takes f7 mate very
nice made and this shows also the
strength of the night on h6 as an
attacking piece this is also a meeting
pattern to remember the night on h6 or
h3 and the bishop on the long diagonal
this happens are not frequently would be
nice if it would happen so often and you
would win the games game of the gamer in
this fashion but it's nice to remember
this that you oftentimes just need a
very strong bishop and this night
helping to h6 an hd2 to build up a nice
mate um okay so rook takes f6 let's have
a look again the problem here is just
that rook f8 is also a deadly made
thread with a double check so black
cannot run also if he if he would try to
try to 4-inch King g7 this is just made
in one with a double check and the only
move to somewhat continue he has 92 g 7
and then ruegg f7 threatening Bishop
trees have made again the night on h6
always taking the g8 square and then
let's say rook to g8 takes with check
only move FA true g8 and looped xg8 mate
Brooke and night combination is just
just deadly for the king so let's recap
this this combination quickly white
starts with 95 to distract the porn here
and then
just enters with its pieces delivering
this deadly check this was all done to
get this check in and very very
important that white needed to see I'm
rook takes f6 of quarters the threat
rook f8 and preserving the bishop to
deliver the final check on the long
diagonal so in the game after rook takes
f7 no black resigned yeah very nice
attacking display it shows on that you
can really get strong and taking
positions even now with fairly solid
looking setups you don't always need to
play the absolute most sharp stuff that
you can find with long castle and
everything forwards so to say it
sometimes interesting to study somewhat
slower looking build up which
nevertheless had gusts has got some
aggressive ideas behind it so I can
recommend to study this kind of setup
like this here if you look for ways to
play against a sicilian without on
studying so much heavy theory because if
you for instance just pick out let's say
10 or 20 of gallows games he played this
kind of set up against the night of
worship skinning and I don't think 40 50
times or something really a lot of games
if you pick out let's say 10 10 or 20 of
them and play through them carefully you
would have a very nice um yeah very nice
starting point to build up in repertoire
again this kind of line you could also
end should also of course have a look at
of current games um this um and this
line is played of course even nowadays
were very strong Grand Master's um if
you look at for instance on Michael
Adams he placed this regularly and
played some very nice games also with
this this opening on and also
I'd say Nigel short still he plays all
kinds of obscure stuff nowadays but once
in a while he goes back to classic main
lines and then you might also find this
the setup so what so it's an interesting
alternative to to the very sharp stuff
um yeah yeah I'm at the end of the game
yeah thanks for watching and if you want
to get some more information about what
geller as a player or some by a yes and
some further information know like a
biography ends and staff are linked to
Wikipedia in the description and dumb
yeah thanks for watching and also the
welcome to make more suggestions about
about new videos and of course all other
comments or questions are also welcome
yeah thanks for watching and till the
next video I think tomorrow I'll make a
couple of more blitz games I just wasn't
in the mood today yes yeah